the lucky few on the last bus for now at
least from St Petersburg to Helsinki the
bus company says it's having to plot
alternative routes after Finland
announced it was closing its four
busiest Southeastern border crossings
with
Russia I'm probably going to have to go
to Talon and then cross to Finland by
ferry but it's still
uncertain what a Pity I wanted to see my
grandson so much and now I won't I don't
know when I'll see him next Finland says
Russia has been deliberately funneling
Asylum Seekers to The Crossings with 300
people mostly from Yemen Iraq Syria and
Somalia arriving this week the Finnish
government says it's been preparing for
such a tactic for months starting work
on a border fence in April shortly after
it angered Moscow by joining
NATO my message to fins is that the
government ensures border security in
all situations we have been following
the situation closely and now we are
taking the actions required Moscow has
denied the accusations saying Finland
was making a big mistake and taking the
path of destroying bilateral relations
in Brussels the European commission
spokesman quoted its president Ursula
velan Russia's instrumentalization of
migrants is shameful I fully support the
measures taken by Finland and I thank
the Finnish border guards for protecting
our European borders other Crossings
between Finland and Russia further north
and less easily accessible remain open
but only two will allow Asylum Seekers
to cross Harry foret Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer